[Music]
so what is your Automator this is
provided by Google and which is the tool
being used by rpm it is you 86 Limbach
mainly used across a functional UI
testing for Android apps
it is our library containing a set of
lightweight API is it helped to build
you a desk hand to interact with
elements in user apps and since the Maps
he means if you if you know if you know
more let me tell you there are two type
of apps one is use an average system
apps system apps are those apps when you
buy a new home the existing apps which
is pre-installed that is called as
system apps which you cannot install I
would say in that time and user apps are
those apps which you download explicitly
and which you can answer who's on call
last user user that's right and so one
of the best who's producing Android app
it is bundled with Android SDK
it is good framework to write black box
test the test would does not interfere
with the application implementation
it supports Android version 4.3 nmo so
currently we have hero Android eight so
of course below this I don't think so
anyone needed and then it says it
provides a viewer going automated where
to inspect element locators it provides
a set of API sruti state of application
and perform actions on apps on a device
who also provides a set of API is that
support cross a few itis Android SDK
whenever you want walk with Android apps
you'll be needing Android SDK and this
is what you download from the Google
site it helps students so there you get
UI Automator viewer okay so let me show
you
so when you install Android SDK actually
on this you know when you download SDK
there are who will set is called Gy
Automator viewer when you click on
this is the SDK what you get from Google
itself correct
it is useful development of apps and it
is actually used other testing in the
apps now as well if your dependence is
connected or if you have created any
simulator then you will click on this
link and it will detect your mobile apps
free or mobile on the screen it will
detect your screen and will show you all
these steps right all in the screenshot
right here and on the right inside it
will show you some zero of herati of
code else will keep like this here is
their app this screenshot and here you
will get all D are you know in a in a
child parent-child relationship you will
find your notes and on the bottom
whenever you move your cursor on any of
these elements it will show you all the
radios on that element that the ID of
that element is this the class of that
element is says the package of the
element is this okay the index is one so
if you tell you each and everything on
that particular you are launched all the
UI Automator viewer I am only launched
today so in that it is saying that go to
the Android SDK tools bin directory and
open that and in that you will find here
link device screenshot which is this
this one devices screenshot when you
click on it it will actually take from
the screen chart of your half power of
your device whatever the home page is
and then it which means the properties
of the element wherever you move your
cursor like the in fire box you move
your cursor on any element in to show
you the properties it shows you the code
of math particular element in the CD it
will show you the properties of that
particular element so here they are just
showing you as an example that how it
looks up you can see that on the left
hand side when they move their cursor on
this it
all the ladies on this section right on
the right side
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here